alors tu m'as pose donc qu'il a peints
s'il te plaît voilà c'est gentil ne vous
y méprenez pas christopher n'est pas à
l'hôpital mais bien dans sa chambre
celle d'un jeune homme de 23 ans fan de
foot et de jeux vidéo ont placé à l'âge
de 9 mois
les médecins lui diagnostiquent une lio
pâtit depuis son état ne cesse de
s'aggraver et rythment le quotidien de
ses parents qu'il faut jamais faire mes
courses ou pour attendre l'après midi
puisque le matin est consacré à
christopher ses pansements à la toilette
perte de la marche difficultés à se
nourrir et depuis 2010 cette assistance
respiratoire
la maladie de christopher prend de la
place pour ces parents difficile de le
soigner dans 13 mètres carrés
c'est compliqué donc je vous dis quand
on fait des changements de trachéotomie
avec les infirmiers on est roi et autour
de lui on est vraiment passé ma sur
l'autre c'est le
l'infirmier principal bon lui il change
la traque la filière secondaire est là
pour le nettoyage ou tous et moi je suis
là pour tout et les aspirations de ces
questions parce le matériel pour
s'allier au plus vite quoi déménager
n'est pas possible pour le moment
alors les parents de christopher se
concentre sur l'achat d'un nouveau
fauteuil l'espoir de plus d'autonomie
pour le jeune homme en fauteuil déjà
adopté lors d'un essai il ya quelques
mois il s'est servi des aces qui peut
faire avec ce genre de fauteuils avec ce
genre de domotique qui sont huit succès
vraiment vraiment génial quoi je savais
que ça nous gêne au rapport de l'espoir
et aussi bien pour lui quoi qu'il puisse
sortir un peu de sa chance et revivre
pitt avec sa famille chose qu'il ne fait
pas actuellement
un bonheur qui a un coût plus de 29
mille euros une somme difficile à réunir
pour la famille m'a l'air pourtant en
contact avec plusieurs associations
face à la baisse des dons il compte sur
une cagnotte en ligne ouverte mi octobre
c'est dur si je vois que ça monte pas
plus que ça c'est comme si on a fait ça
pourrait en fait ça pour ne rien y aura
toujours une peur que les gens soient le
moins généreux mais on a confiance en
eux pour le moment 300 euros récoltés
sur la cagnotte déjà un peu d'espoir
pour christopher